now to the White House where press
secretary and the White House National
Security spokesperson are talking about
those unidentified objects this isn't it
low speed
now let me start with the Chinese
program and President Biden came into
office he directed the U.S intelligence
Community to do a broad assessment of
Chinese intelligence capabilities and to
assure and to ensure that we were
working to detect and to protect against
them
I think for reasons that you will all
understand we cannot publicly go into
many details about how we discover and
counteract foreign intelligence
collection efforts because much of what
we have done and are doing is of course
sensitive
but we were able to determine that China
has a high altitude balloon program for
intelligence collection that's connected
to the people's Liberation Army
it was operating during the previous
administration but they did not detect
it we detected it we tracked it
and we have been carefully studying it
to learn as much as we can
we know that these PRC surveillance
balloons have crossed over dozens of
countries on multiple continents around
the world
including some of our closest allies and
partners
we assessed that at this time these
balloons have provided limited additive
capabilities to the prc's other
intelligence platforms
used over the United States
but in the future if the PRC continues
to advance this technology it certainly
could become more valuable to them
the President also instructed the
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
indeed President Biden conducted the
first ever daily intelligence briefing
session devoted to this phenomenon back
in June of 2021
he was briefed that this is not just an
issue for the United States but one for
the rest of the world and as I said our
friends and our partners are dealing
with this as well
we worked on a bipartisan basis to stand
up an office at the Pentagon to study
this
in partnership with the intelligence
Community academic institutions and the
private sector
these unidentified aerial phenomena have
been reported for many years without
explanation or deep examination by the
government
President Biden has changed all that we
are finally trying to understand them
better
now in light of the Chinese balloon
program and this recent incursion into
our airspace
the United States and Canada through
NORAD have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspace including
enhancing our radar capabilities which
as the commander of North com and NORAD
General van hurk said just last night
May at least partially explain the
increase in the objects that have been
detected
slow moving objects at high altitude
with a small radar cross section are
difficult to detect on radar even
objects the size of a the Chinese Bible
which had a payload the size of roughly
three school buses were not picked up
by previous administrations or other
countries
we also know that a range of entities
including countries companies research
and academic organizations operate
objects at these altitudes for purposes
that are not nefarious at all including
scientific research
that said because we have not yet been
able to definitely definitively assess
what these most recent objects are
we acted out of an abundance of caution
to protect the security our security our
interest and flight safety
in Saturday's case
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government the president
speaking personally with the with prime
minister Trudeau
the Spy balloon was of course different
because we knew precisely where that was
as we have said
we do not assess that these most recent
objects posed any direct threat to
people on the ground and we are laser
focused on confirming their nature and
purpose including through intensive
efforts to collect debris in the remote
locations where they have fallen
in each instance we have followed the
same basic course
we assessed whether they posed any
kinetic threat to people on the ground
they did not
we assessed whether they were sending
any communication signals
we detected none
we looked to see whether they were
maneuvering or had any propulsion
capabilities
we saw no signs of that
and we made sure to determine whether or
not they were manned
they were not
we did however assess that their
altitudes were considerably lower than
the Chinese high altitude balloon and
did pose a threat to civilian commercial
air traffic
and while we have no specific reason to
suspect that they were conducting
surveillance of any kind we couldn't
rule that out
that is why the president at the
recommendation of Secret of the
Secretary of Defense the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and the north
North com NORAD Commander gave the order
to shoot them down
these missions were completed
successfully and safely efforts are
actively underway right now at all sites
to find what is left of those objects so
that we can better understand and
communicate with the American people
what they are
I think it's important to remind the
objects in Alaska and Canada are in
pretty remote Terrain
ice and Wilderness all of that making it
difficult to find them in winter weather
the object over Lake Huron
Now lies in what is probably very deep
water
so outside of recovery operations what
are we doing
well first
We are continuing to monitor
there are no active tracks today
but the professionals at NORAD will
continue to do their important work
secondly we are Consulting with allies
and partners on the challenge of
identified aerial phenomenon
and how we can all work together
to deal with that challenge
the president has directed the secretary
of state Secretary of Defense
and the Director of National
Intelligence to engage with their
relevant counterparts to share
information and to try to gain their
perspectives as well again this is an
issue that affects everybody around the
world
third we will continue to brief members
of Congress and relevant State
leadership on what we are doing and what
we learn president has made this a very
top priority
we have over the course of just the last
few days and certainly over the course
of last week reached out to inform and
brief members of Congress and relevant
State governors of the operations that
we were conducting and other recovery
operations that are underway we've also
kept Congress briefed generally on this
issue of Chinese surveillance balloons
including classified briefings last
August
and last week Administration officials
provided classified briefings for all
senators and all members of the House of
Representatives on the PRC surveillance
balloon we fully expect and anticipate
and support
the ability to continue these briefings
in the days ahead
the fourth
the president through his National
Security adviser has today directed an
interagency team
to study the broader policy implications
for detection analysis and disposition
of unidentified aerial objects that pose
either safety or security risks every
element of the government will redouble
their efforts to understand and mitigate
these events and I'm happy to take some
questions
[Applause]
um John if the objects don't pose a
military threat and they don't pose a
threat to anybody on the ground why
shoot them down particularly because the
military has uh is routinely monitoring
radar you know radar blips I kind of
covered that in the opening statement
um two real reasons here
first there was a very real potential
risk to civilian air traffic
the ones shut down on Saturday I'm sorry
uh yesterday uh was about 20 000 feet
and the two shot down Friday and
Saturday were at about 40 000 feet and
as you know transcontinental air traffic
is roughly around 30 000 feet it depends
of course on on weather and so uh
because we assessed that they weren't
manned and weren't being controlled
therefore left to atmospheric conditions
um the the real risk to safety of flight
was was a problem the second purpose and
I talked about this earlier too was even
though we had no indications
that any of these three objects were
surveilling we couldn't rule that out
and so there you know you want to err on
the side of safety here in terms of
protecting our national security
interests and the fact that these
objects could have and uh and likely did
at some point in their path uh Transit
over you know potential military sites
of ours or sensitive sites so again out
of an abundance of caution for those two
reasons the president with the
recommendation of his military leaders
directed them to be taken down the
because it's so unprecedented
um should the public be hearing from the
president directly on this
we have been
I think as transparent as we can be I
won't speak for the president's uh
personal uh speaking schedule but I mean
he has been deeply engaged in uh every
one of these decisions he's been kept
informed including as of this morning on
what's going on with recovery efforts
um and uh and he's very much staying on
top of the issue and uh and directing
his team
to make sure we are properly Consulting
and briefing not just members of
Congress but State leaders as well and
of course you know we're also doing what
we can in the in the public sphere
thank you John what is the president's
standard going to be going forward about
when he orders an unidentified object
shot down
it's it comes down to
one simple formulation and that's if at
the recommendation of his military
leaders he believes that the Safety and
Security of the United States the Safety
and Security of the American people his
prime responsibility warrant that kind
of a decision so it's possible we could
see these shoot Downs on a regular basis
like we saw over the weekend I don't
think it's useful for me to get ahead of
where we are right now the president
will always side on preserving and
protecting the Safety and Security of
the American people you said we're not
flying any surveillance balloons over
China are we flying any other kind of
surveillance craft routinely over China
we are not flying surveillance balloons
over China I'm not aware of any other
craft that we're flying over into
Chinese airspace and then finally can
you tell us anything more about this
I'm not gonna get into a description
I've seen the Press reports about what
would it look like
um I I think we all need to be humble
here in in terms of what our ability is
to positively identify stuff from
fighter aircrafts that are going several
hundred miles an hour past essentially
in terms of relative motion a stationary
object
um that was not very big
um so we don't know what this exactly
looked like and again we're still not
sure exactly what what it what the
purpose of it was or who owned it but we
we hope to be able to find out more once
we can recover the brief from that one
and from the other two as well
um just a few minutes ago prime minister
Trudeau said that there's some sort of
pattern to the objects over the last few
days is that something you could
elaborate on what sort of pattern the
White House has seen I'm not familiar
with the prime minister's comments so I
I don't know if I uh if I should take a
swing at that I would just tell you that
going back to what I said before
these objects were not being maneuvered
they did not appear to have any
self-propulsion
so the likely hypothesis is that they
were being moved by the prevailing winds
and maybe perhaps that's what the prime
minister is talking about I don't want
to speak for him but certainly
um as the prevailing winds particularly
at that altitude go west to east across
the North American
airspace I mean there was a general
common movement in in that regard and
you spoke at the top about kind of
reassessing radar given what happened
with with the initial balloon can you
give us a sense can we expect uh should
we assume that this is the the regular
number of these objects over the United
States that they've always been there
and they just haven't been um looked at
the same way or is there any reason to
expect that this is this is more than
usual that are flying so two thoughts
there I mean I I think
um I I think we can all
get our heads around the fact that
um that there are sometimes uh things
floating at high altitudes for various
purposes as I said scientific research
weather weather balloons uh all manner
of uh of uh of innocuous craft uh can
can be Aloft at high altitudes I don't
think that that's necessarily unusual
here it's difficult for for me to say
exactly what you can expect going
forward one of the reasons that we think
we're seeing more is because we're
looking for more as you heard uh General
van hurt mentioned last night they have
they have modified the filters and the
gains as we call it of the of the the
radar capabilities to look more
discreetly at high altitude small radar
cross section and low speed objects and
so if you do that and anybody that's
operated a radar will know you can set
you can set the parameters and if you
set the parameters in such a way that to
look for a certain something it's more
likely that you're going to find a
certain something
and given all you've discussed during
the action of the administration of
taking and what people have learned
Chinese spy balloon this year in
previous years these unidentified
objects that we shoot down they might
have a question uh when it comes to
these higher altitudes our America's
borders secure
president takes as I said earlier he
takes our national security uh extremely
seriously he has no higher
responsibility than the Safety and
Security of the American people and I
don't think you need to look any further
quite frankly than the decisions he's
made in just the last week to 10 days to
evidence that but it feels like he's
plugging holes like these are
vulnerabilities that we are discovering
in real time you're making an assumption
there that I don't know that the I don't
know that the analysis will actually
Bear out
thank you very much
um the president gave the order to shoot
down the average over Lake Huron
yesterday where was he what kind of
information did he have when he gave
that order what was brief to him and and
how did he anticipate the outcome of
that he was here in the white house he
was kept constantly informed by uh by
his National Security team and certainly
by the military
um uh he made that decision I don't
couldn't give you the exact time on the
clock but it was uh I believe uh mid to
late morning
um and uh and then it was executed in
the in the afternoon
with their continuing season place in
case there was a reaction from a foreign
government in reaction to shooting that
object down
yesterday the one yesterday yeah well it
was
shot over I mean it was shot over Lake
Huron and landed in what we believe to
be the Canadian side of the lake
um so we were obviously in constant
communication and consultation with our
Canadian counterparts and they are
rightly because of where we think it
splashed down I mean there's sort of the
in concert with the U.S Coast Guard but
they are also involved in in trying to
locate the debris right now but there
was good communication with our Canadian
allies signs of a foreign government
taking a special interest in that object
from yesterday reacting in an unusual
way no okay let's be in the back yeah
thanks uh uh John two questions one you
mentioned early on that um
this the the China uh balloon might have
been giving limited additive
capabilities I assume you're
um meaning onto their satellite
surveillance can you specify what I mean
what exactly it's getting from a balloon
that they're not getting from work
orbiting satellites like gold versus
like dozens with the caveat that we
haven't fully recovered everything
though we have recovered some things
from the bottom of the uh of the
Atlantic
um and we're analyzing that but with
that caveat that we don't know exactly
uh what this uh balloon uh was
surveilling or what its capabilities
were so just in general and I that's an
important caveat that I'd like you to
remember
um when you are at a lower altitude then
space
um you could perhaps get a better
Fidelity uh of uh of uh of uh of imagery
for instance uh of things on the ground
uh when you are not moving at the speed
of a satellite and therefore you know
only getting seconds over a a site when
you can maneuver
Left Right Slow Down Speed up like this
thing could then you can loiter if you
can loiter you can soak in a little bit
more you can spend more time over a
sensitive site some of their satellites
are in geostationary orbit I mean
they're just sitting there Gathering
signals intelligence right so um
what is the benefit I mean is it just to
see what kind of fidelity we're going to
learn more I'd rather not go into any
more detail than that right now we're
going to learn more
um and frankly I think that's a terrific
question you should be asked in Beijing
and then one last one the um you said
that uh before the other object shot
down we're not able
to transmit or we're not transmitting
signals that they did not have any
option that the China balloon did that
have any
um was it emitting signals back I'm not
going to go into more detail about the
capabilities of that we are going to be
studying it and analyzing it there is no
question in our minds that that system
was designed to surveil that that was an
intelligence asset I'll leave it there
Outreach from anywhere in the
administration to the kinds of companies
that produce weather balloons or other
craft that would fit these descriptions
that might be from the commercial or
corporate world to say is this yours or
any kind of Outreach or have you been
hearing from anyone who might say we
have ours they're in this area is any of
that going on now I don't know of any
conversations right now uh Kelly but one
of the reasons why the president
directed Mr Sullivan to put together an
interagency effort is to take a long
look at that and try to learn a little
bit better about who
is up at that altitude doing what uh for
a completely legitimate purposes I think
we we all recognize we need to probably
have a better side picture on that and
that's why the president wants the
center agency effort to take a look
they're kind of intelligence might be
happening in terms of the diplomacy
that's going on or whatever if these are
state-owned uh
objects I'm not sure I understand what
you mean is there is there a network of
conversations that might be happening
where someone might be able to say based
on this
octagonal description that hey that
sounds like the so-and-so I mean
is there some conversations that are
happening that might be able to give us
some descriptions I mean the short
answer to your question is yes and I
talked about that in my opening
statement the President also directed
secretary blank and secretary Austin uh
director Haynes uh to have these kinds
of conversations with our allies and
partners around the world to share with
them what we're learning but also to see
get that get their perspectives we're
quick to say it's ours but it was for
commercial purposes
yeah again we're going to have those
kinds of conversations with our with our
allies and partners to see what kind of
experiences that they have had what uh
what we can learn from from them what
perhaps they can learn from us deal with
object or can we call them balloons
still with object
I won't mess that up today on the
corporate angle is there any expectation
that this is going to affect the the
executive order on surveilling the U.S
companies and what they're doing in
China and the their I know exactly okay
and then um is there and just you said a
moment ago that there's no knowledge of
a U.S balloon or other craft over
Chinese territory just being cognizant
of the fact that China has a different
definition of what their territory is
than the United States is there any U.S
surveillance aircraft over Taiwan over
uh the South China Sea that that would
would fit into that there is no U.S
surveillance aircraft uh over Chinese in
Chinese airspace
Chinese claimed airspace there's no U.S
surveillance aircraft and Chinese
airspace and then just finally is there
any
um new formal approach that's being
developed as far as how you're going to
deal with these things on a systematic
basis going forward is there well again
again that's what that's exactly what
the the president wants Mr Sullivan to
run as the process an Interac process to
help us as I said in my opening
statement get around the policy
implications here and whether and
whether or not there needs to be any uh
policy changes going forward
um there's no president for U.S Fighters
taking down objects over U.S territories
as far as I'm aware of I guess my
question is
you talked about the The Tweak in the
radar systems yes there's been a tweak
on the threshold for uh the Pentagon uh
presenting to the president president
signing off on military action related
to anything over our airspace I'm not
sure I'm following which is
Five Below yeah The Radars were tweaked
which is why you think you're seeing
some of these things right has the
decision about or has a threshold for
the use of Fighters to take down objects
also been tweaked because if it lowered
has it been changed we've never seen
this before all of a sudden we've seen
no actually I'm sorry I didn't
understand it at first no I mean and you
heard General van hurt talk about this
last night and he's using established
protocols
um to engage
um
the crafting in the air aircraft in the
air that can be legitimately brought
down and as he said last night the best
way to do that certainly in a timely and
efficient effective way was through
fighter aircraft and through the
Sidewinder air-to-air missiles and they
looked at and he talked about this they
looked at other options to try to bring
them down to include gunfire but that
would have presented a greater risk to
the pilots themselves so this was the
safest most effective way to do that now
where we go from here I think we just
don't know right now in terms of whether
there needs to be threshold changes as
you put out
I think it's important to just take a
step back here and and remember what the
president did was ordered these actions
with the Safety and Security of the
American people foremost in his mind
um and there were there were very good
reasons to do it
um the military then once given an order
determines how they're going to execute
that order
and general van hurk decided that the
best way to do this was with Sidewinder
missiles and fighter aircraft on it this
isn't reactive to the Chinese five
aluminum since there was political
pressure and so we are going to act
quickly to take down any objects over
our airspace because the pressure that
came from State Republic this was this
was these were decisions based uh purely
and simply on what was in the best
interest of the American people
thanks John John does the US government
have video or imagery of these latest
intercepts and will you guys be
releasing it you'd have to talk to DOD
about that Jackie I I don't know what
kind of imagery might exist and uh and
they'd be one to talk about whether
they're releasable or not
um obviously
certainly with respect to the Spy
balloon
we want to make sure that we are
gleaning what we can from this imagery
so that we can answer your questions
better
um and so to what degree there is or
will it will or will not be public
release I do want to stress that you
know we're going to want to make sure
that we have had a chance to analyze
that imagery uh for ourselves as much as
possible
reason but what we're getting at is you
know why are we all of a sudden shooting
them down and
to add to that you know the NORAD
Commander for instance said that uh when
the first spy balloon was crossing over
Americans and Canadian airspace one of
the reasons that he couldn't take action
was because his assessment was that it
didn't pose a military threat or have
hostile intent and so he couldn't take
action there it seems like maybe that
protocol has changed or his his ability
to make that call where there is not an
imminent threat militarily or physically
might have changed so can you explain to
us
what change why are we shooting them
down all of a sudden I kind of feel like
I took care of that in my opening
statement but I'm happy to revisit it I
mean really two reasons here uh and
these are
in certainly in
well in both cases they're different I
think we need to separate the Chinese
Bible and we knew what it was
we knew where it was going
we knew what he was trying to do and by
not taking it down I mean that was also
a huge payload like I said the size of
three school buses so really the option
of shooting that down over land wasn't
the legitimate option because somebody
really could have gotten hurt and we
used the the time available to us
knowing what this thing was all about we
used that time to study it to learn from
it to collect on it
then taking it down at the earliest
opportunity in the water and we have
retrieved some of that debris off the
bottom and we're studying that hang on a
second I'll be right there
um
so let's separate that from these other
three and these other three
what are some of the differences
altitude's a big difference
let me let me get through this and then
altitude's different the Chinese spy
balloon was at sixty thousand plus well
outside commercial air traffic concerns
these three were right on the border of
it so there was a legitimate concern
there
Chinese by balloon we knew exactly what
that thing was and we knew what it was
trying to do and we saw it Jackie as it
slowed down sped up maneuvered a little
bit trying to get a look at what we
believe to be sent to the military sites
these other three they didn't have
propulsion they weren't being maneuvered
it was basically they've been being
driven uh by the by the wind
we don't think we don't we don't know
for sure whether they had a surveillance
aspect to them but we can't rule it out
so there was a little bit there was
enough uncertainty there uh that again
out of an abundance of caution doing The
Prudent thing the president directed
that they get taken down and I I get
where you're going is this the standard
going forward and we're gonna we're
gonna dive into this we're going to
learn from these three events
um we're going to continue to study what
happened we're gonna have an interagency
effort that helps us get around the
policy implications here and we'll see
where this goes but bottom line for
President Biden is you got to do the
right thing for the American people for
our Safety and Security
strange that no one's claimed these yet
is theirs
uh I I can't say whether that's strange
or not since we're sort of in Uncharted
Territory here no pun intended but we
don't you know we don't we don't know
and I suspect that that wait
go ahead I'm I'm basically done